fasal faster slump Sky News Prime
Minister are you not in denial about the
chances of getting this deal through
Parliament and for the critics in your
own party there have been sending in
letters very publicly is it time for
them to put up or shut up what I have as
I think you may have heard me say in the
House of Commons earlier today as I've
just reiterated here I'm going to do my
job of bringing back the best deal for
the United Kingdom that will then be put
before the House of Commons it will be
put before members of parliament in a
meaningful vote their job will be to
look at that deal their job will be to
consider the interests of their
constituents and their job will be to
consider how we can deliver on the vote
of the British people to leave the
European the European Union and I think
you know I think most people watching
this or listening to to this will
recognize that this is not an easy thing
to do this is a complex negotiation but
I think what most people want to know is
that what we will deliver will be in
their interests it will protect jobs it
will protect security it will ensure a
great future for this country